So far, I've only kind of looked at grey-scale images.
Let's step back and now actually go back to color images.
So, this is the original color image, the mandrill image,
that we've looked at before.
What we want to do now is start thinking about is,
what makes this a color image?
Well, basically, what we need to now start thinking about is,
what is a red channel?
What is a green channel and a blue channel?
In essence, I'm going to claim this,
this image is actually divided into, three different color channels.
So now I'm going to slowly and
slowly show you the three different channels, starting with the blue channel.
Of course, each color image is of three channels with their own intensities.
This is the blue channel.
If you notice here the regions in this image which has a lot more blue, is,
of course, more white because that's where the maximum intensity is.
In the green case, if you notice, these parts have a lot more white colors.
And in the case of red channel, this part, of course, is the brightest.
So, in essence, these are the three different channels, and
these merge together.
Blended together create our color image.
So this now makes us want to add one aspect
addition to the resolution of the image.
That is we have a width, we have a height and
of course we have number of channels.
So in essence if this was a 512 by 512 image, we would also have three channels.
And therefore, actually, our resolution would be 512 by 512 times three.
And following from that, each pixel therefore has three intensities.
Each and every pixel in this color image has a red color value,
a green value and a blue value, and composite of this gives us a color image.
I'll recall from last time that each grey scale image is basically represented
by a, a range of grey values from 0 to 255.
That is also true for each and everyone of the color channels, 0 to 255.
And remembering that basically we said that we needed eight pixel,
eight bit image.
To be able to get a range from zero to 255, because that's what we needed.
Well, now, if I wanted to have three of them,
basically you can imagine the range is going to be 24 bits to
be able to get a much bigger range than we have right now.
And that's what basically we mean by an eight-bit grayscale image or
a 24-bit color image.